So, according to multiple intelligence theory, there's a lot of different forms
of intelligence. But, is there any evidence to actually support this?
>> Yes, there is. In fact, some of the strongest evidence to support Gardner's
theory of multiple intelligences comes from savants. And savants are people who
have uncanny cognitive ability and at the same time, uncanny cognitive
disability. So for instance, they might be able to remember things, calculate
things or have incredible musical talent. And yet at the same time, they really
have other cognitive disabilities. So we'll be talking more about this later on
in the lesson. But the thing to take away right now is the fact that this
mismatch between cognitive ability and disability supports Gardner's theory.
Other evidence suggests that there is something in between. This intelligence
says one thing or intelligence is as many things.
>> Are you talking about the Catal Horrell theory of intelligence?
>> Yes I am.
>> I think I'm going to go explain that now.